- Hi everyone I'm Dan
Tieu, from Khan Academy.
Unfortunately after
about a month and a half,
Sal's unable to join us today,
but you do have myself
and another Khan Academy
team member, Meaghan Pattani,
who's here to kinda hold down
the fort while Sal's away
and he'll be joining us tomorrow,
so don't worry about that.
Before we get started if
you have any questions,
please start putting
them into the comment box
and the team will surface the
questions for us to answer
and we'll do our best to
do our Sal impersonations.
(laughs)
So, for those of you who are
joining us for the first time,
this is just a way for
us to stay connected,
especially at a time of social distancing
and school closers.
Khan Academy's a non-profit,
with a mission to provide everyone a free,
world class education to anyone, anywhere.
And the way we've been doing
that for the last 10 plus years
is really by creating
resources from Pre-K,
with Khan Academy Kids,
through Elementary school,
Middle school and High school.
Covering courses in Math, ELA,
Humanities, Sciences and more
and when this crisis hit we recognized
that it was our duty to do even more.
We've created daily
schedules and learning plans
to help provide structures
for remote learning.
We've recorded parent and
teacher webinars in mass,
to provide guidance and
answer pressing questions
and we've even launched Khan
Academy Kids YouTube channel
with daily circle time, and
all of this in an effort
to keep everyone learning
through school closers.
I wanna remind everyone
that we are non-profit,
we're funded by Philanthropic donations
by folks like yourself, and
we were running at a deficit
before the crisis and we've
seen our surfer usages increase
two to three times what we normally incur
and what that means is we
also have increased costs.
And I wanna send a special shout-out
to several organizations who
were the some of the first
to step up and help us during this crisis.
So Bank of America, Google.org,
AT&T, NOVARTIS and Fastly,
have all really stepped in to help
us close some of that gap,
but we need more so, if you find yourself
in a position to do so, please
think about supporting us
and if you have any questions,
you can start adding them
to the message boards
and we'll try to get
trough as many as we can.
So, Meaghan we have a really
great question from YouTube
from Gamermash, I'm going
through high school next year,
I'm already worrying
about working too much,
how can I keep up so I'm
ready for high school?
- That's a great question
and first things first,
take a deep breath.
I'm certain that you have a
great support system around you
and remember that you're not in it alone
a lot of students are asking themselves
that question right now, right?
You've had a huge disruption to the end
of your Middle school experience
and taking on high school
is such a huge challenge in and of itself.
I was a high school teacher for nine years
and I always loved that
fresh look of new students
and how they are eager to learn
and still trying to adapt
and find who they are as they change.
Well we've got some great resources
to help you on the academic
side of that, for sure.
We have a learning plans for Math
that we have things to
help you with the content
you're looking at right now,
in terms of daily schedules,
to help you stay on track
with what you're trying
to finish right now
and then there's learning
plans for over the summer,
to either look more at
what you might be learning
to finish eighth grade or
maybe to get you a step ahead,
so maybe that content
doesn't feel as intimidating
as you step trough that first door.
The other thing we might
be able to support you,
is we have some great
grove mindset content.
And that might be able to help
you frame what you're learning,
and that experience, and
how you can prepare yourself
for learning across subjects
and even beyond the academic.
And so I would really take a look
at both our daily schedules,
and our weekly learning plans
that you can see on the screen right now,
to get ahead in what you might be learning
in Math, come the fall.
- Yeah, I would just
plug the learning plans,
we just hosted a Parent webinar last week
on how to best utilize it,
it was really for parents
but it's also, as a student,
you can use that as well.
It's really just a way
to add a lot of structure
and to make sure that,
you know the summer slide
really doesn't get amplified,
especially in a time of shool closers.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- We have a question on
YouTube from Jrfoster,
what are some of your
recommended books for teenagers
to read during this quarantine?
I can pitch something, so
right now I've been reading,
Percy Jackson and The Olympians,
with my nice and nephews,
we're on book two, Sea of Monsters.
It's way better than the movies were,
I find it's really action packed
and we also have a
recommended reading list
from our Khan Academy Staff.
Meaghan do you have a recommendation?
- First of all, I
absolutely love those books,
I read them a few years ago
and I'm with you Dan, I say the books
are significantly better than the movie.
Some books for high school
students well that's,
I mean there's plenty of things out there.
I'm a Harry Potter fan myself
and I think that you know,
that's always a great thing to look into.
The other thing is,
I know there's some suggestive
reading list out there,
I mean some of our staff has provided
some suggested reading lists
on that same, keep learning, micro site
that we shared on the screen a moment ago.
And so I would definitely take a look,
at some of their suggestions
because we've some really wonderful people
on staff who have put some deep thought
into what they might suggest.
The other thing I would say is that
the important thing is
that you're reading.
And so, I think it's often
underestimated that while
it's great that you know,
maybe you're looking
for some recommended
books from your teachers
or from you know maybe our staff
but the important thing
is that you're reading.
So, if there's something that interest you
and is really engaging you,
whether that be, you know a blog or a book
or you know maybe it's something else
I can't even think of right now,
but as long as you're reading,
what's really important is
that you're engaging yourself
and more than specifically
any individual book.
- Meaghan, we have a question
on YouTube from Eliot H,
it's actually for both of us.
What are our roles at Khan Academy?
How long have we been here?
And how has Khan Academy
changed during your Tenure?
So, I'm on the marketing team,
I lead the channel marketers
and our product marketing folks here,
and I've been at Khan Academy
for, coming up on two years.
I don't know if it's changed that much,
I just feel like it's a team
of extremely passionate people,
everyone's super motivated
to provide that free,
world class education
to anyone anywhere and so I think for me,
it's just been a pleasure coming to work
every single day with a team
that's just an incredible team.
- That's beautiful Dan, we
like working with you too.
(laughs)
- And for those who don't know,
Meaghan is actually my desk partner
so I sit right next to Meaghan.
and Meaghan do you wanna kind of do
a brief overview of what you do?
- Sure, I would love to.
As Dan mentioned his
on the marketing team,
so am I, work on our US
district partnership team
and I lead our US
Professional Learning Aparat,
so what that means is,
I work with teachers
and school districts all over the US
and I design the teacher
facing resources on our site,
to better support teachers
as they use Khan Academy
with students and so, like I mentioned,
I was an educator for nine years
and now I get to work with
educators all over the US
and that's super exciting,
and I know part of the
question has been how long
have I been at Khan Academy,
I've been here a little over two years.
and one thing I've seen evolve,
is that Khan Academy always
cared deeply about teachers
and students and I think we've even tried
to improve that connection
with teachers and students
and district administrators even more so,
and we spend more time
connecting with them
face to face, now, than
we did even before.
- Meaghan, we have a really good question,
I think this is really
important for us to surface,
so on YouTube Daniel Yang
asked, would you make videos
in different languages?
Daniel lives in a non
English speaking country
and I always recommend
Khan Academy to my friends.
So, in short, yes, Meaghan
do you wanna provide
a little bit more info?
- Yeah, I would love to.
So Khan Academy is available
in 50 plus languages
and we have an amazing team
of both employees and
volunteers, called advocates,
who not just translate the videos,
but the localize them.
We have experts who are
creating similar videos
on the same content,
but that have real, local,
meaningful, cultural examples,
so it doesn't just feel
like we're voicing over
Sal's original videos
but we're making content
that is important and
connects to the students
and teachers and leaders, in
those particular countries.
The other piece I would
really highlight here,
is that even within the
US, we find that schools
really love having their parents
and their community involved
in their students learning.
And so if you have a student
who's learning on Khan Academy,
they can change their language
from in school and out of school,
so that parents and
families and communities
can support their learners
in the language they're most comfortable.
So, maybe as a parent, you
didn't grow up in the US system
but you really wanna
support your child learning
but you're most comfortable
in your own language,
you can adjust that at home,
in your settings feature,
and so your child can
learn with you at home
in the language you are most comfortable,
and then they can switch that content back
to English or whatever
their primary language
they're learning in at school.
And again, we have 50 plus
languages on our website
and most of the languages are available
on our app as well,
and so you're seeing a few
of those go past right now.
And I can't stress enough,
how grateful we are for
our international teams
and for our volunteers,
who are really the ones
that make a lot of this work happen.
- Yeah I wanna double down
and just give a shout-out
to those advocates,
because they are an amazing
team around the world,
of folks who are really volunteering
their time to do this
and to Meaghan's point,
they really are localizing
and taking the opportunity to make things,
not only relevant in a
language perspective,
but in a cultural perspective as well so,
it's really important to highlight
that there's a huge team who's doing that.
So, we have a question
from Scot Yan, on Facebook.
Hi Dan today at 1:30pm more
than 40 badges were retired,
was this an accident or do
you intend to make new badges?
I can actually speak to that.
So, as some of you may
or may not already know,
we have a broad effort to make changes,
we have a huge infrastructure project,
in which we're upgrading
some more infrastructural platforms.
And unfortunately part of that,
we had to evaluate some product features
and things in terms of what
we will be porting over
in our new platform and what we can't.
And badges, we all though we love badges
and I'm sure everyone
really appreciates them,
there's a lot of complexity in the badges
that we do have and so
we did make the decision
to retire 40 badges as mentioned,
and the team is working hard to figure out
once we pour over,
what are the new motivation mechanics
that we'll be able to surface,
some of that might be badges
and some of it not but
yes we will be replacing
that at some point, just can't guarantee
a time and what that might
look like just yet, Alright.
We have a great question on YouTube
from Arechan Plays.
Khan Academy do you work with teachers
in Canada too, Meaghan?
- We do not work directly,
in the same way we work
with school districts in the US.
However, we are really grateful for input
and feedback from teacher across the globe
including Canada of course.
So I highly encourage you,
that if you are a teacher in Canada
or any place in the world,
to provide us feedback
on what is and is not working for you
or for your students or for your school.
And if you go to our help center,
there's places to provide feedback
or if you have questions or
sort, I really recommend.
- I think we've lost
Meaghan for a second there.
Sorry Meaghan, you
popped out for a second.
- Yeah, I see that.
- I you don't mind repeating
the last like sentence or two.
- Yeah, no problem.
Let me check my connection
here just a second here.
Is that, okay?
- That's good.
- Alright, let's try that again,
while we don't work directly
with teachers in Canada
the way we do in the US,
we do really value feedback
from teachers across the globe.
And if you have questions or feedback
or any great ideas you'd
love to share with us,
we're so eager to get those,
and I highly recommend visiting
our help center, where you
can provide that feedback,
or questions or seek community responses
and we do actually read those
and take those into consideration,
when we are making changes to the product
or improving our teacher resources.
So please, if you have feedback
we love to hear from you.
- Great, and Meaghan we
have a question on YouTube
from Jrfoster, I think both of
us can answer this question.
What are some good study habit tips,
for us to use during these troubled times?
I think part of what we
try to do at Khan Academy,
by providing the daily schedules
as well as the learning plan,
is to try to provide some structure.
I think part of it is building
just good habits on a daily bases.
Now, it doesn't have to be so ridged
that you feel that you're
struggling to do something,
so, you know, alter it as you need.
But I think our goal in doing
that is really to create
kind of like a light weight daily habit.
So I've mentioned,
as Meaghan mentioned
earlier about reading.
It's not so much important you
know exactly what you read,
as long as you're practicing reading
and I think that the same
thing goes with studying.
I don't think you have to
follow one prescription
at least personally, as
long as your doing something
a little bit everyday.
- I would echo that
Dan, is that I know that
everyone out there learns differently
and that's part of what's so wonderful
about learning, right?
People can approach things differently
and the same is true with study habits,
just because it works for one person
doesn't mean it works for someone else.
And I think leveraging the schedules
we provided, to have some structure,
but adapting that to what works for you
and that once you find something
that works really well,
I would stick with it.
I wouldn't continue to
experiment over and over again.
Like Dan mentioned,
providing some structure
that works for you and sticking with it.
And we know that it's really challenging
and don't be too upset if you need a day
to just take a break for yourself,
and then come back
reinvigorated to work harder.
- And Meaghan we have another
personal question here.
Anush Baguone asked, how
do you boost yourself
when you feel low at some points in life?
Do you wanna tackle that first Meaghan
and then I'll chime in?
- Yeah, I think that's a tough question.
(laughs)
I would say for me I'm really grateful
for such a phenomenal support system.
First of all, I would say husband
has been a huge piece of my life
when I fell down or made a career change
or things like that.
And then taking some
time to really reflect,
and I know Sal's really big on meditation,
but taking that time to reflect
on some of the really great
things that you've worked hard,
and been able to see those
outcomes be really powerful.
And then think about how
in your current situation,
you can use those skills and learnings
you've had in the past, to
move your self forward now.
so, I would say, really
good support system
and reflection to you know,
make progress forward,
is really important for me.
- Yeah, I would echo the reflection piece,
I think for me that's
really effective as well,
You know looking at,
not just reflecting on myself
but also just looking at the challenge
in from different perspectives,
like even now in a global pandemic, right?
I do think there are silver linings.
One thing's that, you know
this could be a very
depressing state and time.
I think for me one of the
things that really motivates me
is, you know behind the
scenes here at Khan Academy,
you know, we work hard on a daily basis,
but you can see the passion
that your fellow co-workers
have during this time,
to really help people who
need the help most, right?
Like Sal himself, Sal's been working
24/7 for the last month and a half.
Some of you, you know kind
of see him here and there
but you know he's waking up at 5am
for calls on the East Coast,
for some medium edge,
and he's working at six,
seven, eight o'clock at night
to draft the daily learning schedules.
And I would say that's indicative
of almost everyone here at Khan Academy,
you know aside from the challenge
of just dealing with the
crisis on a personal level,
everyone feels super
passionate about helping out.
And I think that one has
really, and particularly for me,
just been so inspirational
and it's really, kind of helped
lift my spirits during this time.
- Alright, YouTube, we have
a question from Araf Jane.
What do I do when my brain gets
stressed in reading or math?
So, I think Meaghan, you
already alluded to a little bit,
Sal's been high on the meditation piece,
do you wanna speak to that a little bit?
- Sure, so Sal's been encouraging,
I think all of us to take a moment
to breath and meditate
and maybe take a look
at some of the guided meditations
that he's recommended,
or find a space just to take a step back.
This can be a really,
you know math or learning
can be really intimidating,
in a what we think of,
as a normal experience
and only increases right now.
So don't be too overwhelmed
to take a step back
and give your mind an opportunity
to take a break, right?
There's always time to go
back and work on that problem
but sitting there and
repeatedly getting frustrated
with the same thing, when you're not,
you know, having a productive
struggle to move forward,
take a step back.
Maybe take a moment to meditate or step
and do something else,
and then come back to the work,
so that you're giving your
brain a chance to relax,
instead of just trying to grind trough it.
- Perfect, we have two questions
and actually, this one's two questions,
one from Dave Hanken on YouTube.
I'm a teacher who do, what
do you feel are some ways
to motivate students to
actually do the work?
and then Sam Laratum, from I
meet new walker on Facebook.
How do I keep my fourth grader motivated
to study with schools not starting until
the new school year?
so, I'm gonna take a moment to plug
our parent webinar that we'll
be giving this Wednesday
on motivation.
So we have a fabulous
ambassador, Connor Corrie,
who's also a teacher and a parent
and Connor's gonna be walking through
like the the top tips for motivating
your child during this time.
And that's gonna be on Wednesday
from 3pm Pacific, 6pm Eastern.
And for those of you who can't attend
that particular webinar,
we'll be posting the recording
and sharing that out as we go.
But in the mean time Meaghan,
do you have a couple of tips
for these, for, Amead and Dave?
- Sure, so couple of
things we've been hearing
from parents and teachers are,
you know one, taking the
time to learn with your child
or student if you are showing them
maybe something you're learning,
you know, this is an opportunity, right?
I think the, you can
learn anything, sprit,
is really true and in what
you might be able to learn
alongside them, has been really great.
We've seen teachers get really creative
about how they're motivating students
and I think some of those
can easily be translated
as a parent as well.
So we've seen teachers do things
like leverage side walk chalk,
and visit homes and put
math problems on driveways
and then have students take picture
and send them back.
Or mailing cards just to
say I'm thinking of you.
Or you know, letting their
child make a TikTok video
with them, in Halloween costumes.
So, things that are really unique
and aren't necessarily high cost,
but really able to encourage students
to learn something new and see a unique
and fun reward for doing so.
- Great, Philippe maybe
it's time for us to do
a couple of social media mentions.
So with Sal not here today,
one of the things that
I just wanna call out
from some of us behind the scenes,
we are so appreciative of all
of the social media mentions
and comments and
testimonials that we received
from all of you.
And I think it's worth sharing out
because we get some amazing ones
and then also if, please keep them coming,
I think they add to kinda the inspiration
and motivation that you, that the team
has when we get to see something
amazing from all of you.
So, Sal can you put up a number eight,
a tweet and photo from JacobZik?
Yep so, Jacob says,
supplementing Google Classrooms
with Khan Academy,
the greatest value to be
derived here is mathematics,
science and coding, my
daughter's chef interests.
Most parents at this time
want kids to get it all right,
but failure is a good thing,
it aids the learning process.
so, I think that's a
terrific comment Meaghan,
do you wanna speak a little
bit to a learning mindset,
'cause it really does speak to
building upon you know,
challenges that you may have?
- Yeah, I think building a growth mindset
is something we all strive to achieve.
And it's the idea that, you know,
smart is not something you are,
but something you can work towards
and it's a process, right?
Learning is a process and
having the understanding
that failing does not mean failure.
You always have the opportunity
to grow and learn something new.
your brain is a muscle
and the more you use it,
the stronger it gets.
So taking those opportunities of struggle
and understanding that you learn more
buy struggling and being
able to reach something
and how great that is when
you finally reach that.
And we have some great supporting content,
building collaboration
with parts at Stanford
so, if you're new into
that growth mindset,
that learning mindset experience,
we have some resources
for both you know
Elementary and Middle school
and for high school.
And for teachers, we have
lesson plans that guides,
that go along with that content.
So we encourage you to
leverage pieces of that
or all that, as much as
that's helpful to you,
and then understand that all of us, right?
You're not born with the ability
to understand Algebra, right?
Think about a small child
learning to walk, right?
You can't just stand up
and do it all in one day.
So being able to build your brain
in that same type of way
and building those skills overtime
and using failures as opportunity to grow,
is just, again ,something
we all really strive
to work with here at Khan Academy,
and we encourage others to do as well.
- Great, we have a question on Facebook
from Thasha Wright Knocks.
My kids have been using
Khan for many years,
how do I get them to
watch instructional videos
not done by Sal.
They only want Sal kinda like
when Steve left Blue's Clues.
I did love Steve on Blue's Clues as well,
so I definitely sympathize here.
I don't have a great answer
for this Meaghan, maybe you do?
- I think that's a tough one,
we all get comfortable with
what we know and change is hard.
I think even I, hearing other voices,
other the Sal sometimes, you
know throws me for a loop,
but understanding that there's
so much value in diversity
and being able to hear other
voices and see other faces.
and so, I think just keep encouraging them
and maybe if you can find one other voice
or one other thing that interests them,
maybe if the topic is interesting first
and then the voice narrating that
or learning alongside your students,
you know, help support that.
but I would definitely say Sal's voice
is absolutely wonderful.
Obviously, of course we're
huge fans here at Khan Academy,
but being able to support diverse voices
and views is really important.
And I would say even on our own site,
if you look at some of
our grammar content,
you'll hear our colleague David.
Or if you look at some
of our history content,
you'll hear our colleague Kim.
So, even starting
elsewhere on Khan Academy,
look around, you'll hear some
other voices other than Sal.
- Yeah, and I would also say
I mean, the other thing is,
try to introduce something new everyday
and if your child doesn't like that,
or doesn't respond, try
a different instructor
and hopefully they'll pick
up on somebody else as well.
So, Meaghan we have a
question for you on Facebook
Sahid, sorry if I'm
mispronouncing, Alamas.
Are you planning to give
your amazing teacher training
in Bihar, India?
We, actually have an
amazing Khan India team,
so, Meaghan, you wanna speak to that?
- Yes, we have an incredible team in India
and they are working on some
incredible teacher resources
and scaling training to schools in India.
And so, my first recommendation
would be to check out
the Khan for Educators India
course that you can view
anywhere on our India site
and so I would start there.
Our incredible team has put together
some really thoughtful resources
about supporting teachers
and learners in India.
As we mentioned earlier,
we know that it's important
not just to translate content,
but to localize to the needs and culture
and aspects of individual,
you know countries and areas.
And so, a huge applause
to my teammates in India,
and to look at that content
and I would contact them if
there are specific trainings.
I know they had things
planed for Impersiam,
but of course with the pandemic,
a lot of that has been put on pause.
But I would take a look
at the opportunities
they have there and it's really,
really wonderful for teachers
and learners in India.
- Great, and then we have
a SAT question on YouTube
from Richie Gooptha.
Is college board going
to add more SAT dates?
So, I think you know,
one thing I would like to comment here,
is I think we just all need
to be a little bit patient,
I think there is still a lot of unknowns.
I know college, I get a
pleasure of actually working
with a college team pretty closely.
I know that for the upcoming dates,
they have increased the number
of seats pretty significantly
and so they're trying to accommodate
for this upcoming situation.
I know they have a
desire to add more dates,
I'm not aware of any that
are coming up right away.
I think part of the challenge
is, you know the uncertainty
of one, we're gonna go back
to kind of a normal schedule
and then, how do we add
those dates around that.
So, I don't have a great answer for that,
but as soon as the college board
is able to announce
anything, they'll send it out
and we'll also send out
that information to you
as soon as we have any of that, okay.
Here's a question on
YouTube from Jrfoster.
What made both of you want
to work at Khan Academy?
I can answer that first Meaghan,
and then you know if you wanna jump in.
So, for my self personally,
it was complete serendipity.
So, I have always been
a fan of Khan Academy
from the first time I saw Sal's
TikTok, way back in the day.
And then I was kind of just
browsing the job boards,
when I saw Khan Academy's position open
and it fit everything that
I wanted to get out of,
out of my professional life you know
so, as a marketer I'm always interested
in you know the marketing work,
the functional work it's self.
But I always was looking for something
that was very mission
orientated, foreign organization
and I wanted to be a teacher
growing up, to be honest,
that was one of the things I
was really passionate about.
I was a tutor in high school,
it was something that really
just give me a lot of
motivation and energy
and unfortunately as a first generation,
you know immigrant family,
my parents did not want me
to become a teacher unfortunately.
So, I felt like this was
the best of both worlds,
where I get to you know
use my Marketing chops,
but I get to do in a way
that I still get to bring
education to kids and
family's all around the world.
Meaghan, yourself?
- That's really beautiful Dan.
(laughs)
Yeah, I was a high school
Science teacher for nine years
and during that time I
did use Khan Academy,
a little bit with my students.
But one thing that was always a challenge
for me as a teacher,
is that wanted to be able
to reach more students.
And Khan Academy was such a powerful tool
and Sal's approach to learning
was so powerful for me
and my students that it
was, as you mentioned,
kind of serendipitous
for me to find a role
that I was able to make the
switch from classroom teacher,
to working in Educational Technology.
And now I feel like I'm
able to help more students
beyond the walls of my classroom
and I hope that it feels that way
to teachers and learner sometimes.
And I'm really grateful to work with,
such incredibly passionate people like Dan
and the rest of our team,
who are just so committed
to our mission to provide a
free, world class education,
to anyone, anywhere.
And I'm so grateful for the opportunity
to be a piece of that.
- Yeah, so I think we're at time.
Meaghan, thanks for joining me today.
I know it was little bit of last minute,
but I'm happy to have you here.
- Thanks for having me Dan.
(laughs)
- So, thank you audience for joining us.
Sal will be back tomorrow
with guest Mellody Hobson
from Ariel Investments.
And they'll be covering the
economic impact of this.
And I wanted to again,
thank you all for joining.
If you liked what you heard here today,
if you like Sal's Daily Homeroom,
please remember to like, subscribe, follow
and let your friends,
families and colleagues
know about this session
and about Khan Academy.
We have active communities
on Facebook, Instagram,
Twitter and YouTube and so thank you
for being a part of that and
please share Khan Academy
with other people, and with that, goodbye.